من خلال تسييس النباتيه يصبح اختلاف
الاراء السياسيه حول القضايا البيئيه هو
المحرك الاساسي لها وحتى الوصول الى حل
للخلافات السياسيه يبدو ان القضيه
الاساسيه تضيع في التفاصيل وهي ان اكل
اللحوم المصنعه هو النوع الاكثر اهدارا
واضرارا بيئيا
ليست النباتيه وحدها التي تدق ناقوس خطر
الكارثه البيئيه التي يتجه اليها العالم
حيث انبثقت عن فلسفتها مجموعات اخرى تفرعت
في قضاياها وتطرفت في اساليبها
لم يمضي على خروج في بيبلمر من السجن
بكفاله سوى بضعه اسابيع كانت واحده من بين
العشرات من الناشطين الذين اعتقلوا بعد
قطعهم طريقا سريعا في لندن والقاء الطعام
على لوحات فنيه مشهوره احتجاجا على
استخراج الوقود الاحفوري خرجت فيبي لتجد
ان لها قاعده شعبيه بين العديد من الماره
يقفون بين الحين والاخر يباركون لها ما
فعلته في المعرض الوطني في اكتوبر الماضي
لا يزال غريبا القول انني دخلت السجن انا
لست مجرمه انا مجرد شابه خائفه واحاول
المكافحه من اجل مستقبلي الحكومه تخاطر
بكل شيء بتجاهلها علمائها ومستشاريهم كم
عدد الخبراء الذين يحتاجون حتى يتسنى
للعوده الى حياه الطبيعيه الطلابيه هل
تعتقدين ان الذهاب الى السجن والاعتقال
والذهاب الى المحكمه امر ممتع الامر ليس
كذلك ولكن لا يمكنني التراجع